IT IS OVER FOR NEW YORK GOVERNOR
ANDREW CUOMO, BUT NOT THE END OF
HIS MANY PROBLEMS.
HE RESIGNED TODAY AFTER A REPORT
THAT FOUND HE HAD SEXUALLY
HARASSED NEARLY ONE DOZEN WOMEN.
HE SAYS HE WILL STEP ASIDE 14
DAYS FROM NOW.
I THINK GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IS IF I STEP ASIDE AND LET
GOVERNMENT GET BACK TO THE
GOVERNING.
THAT'S WHAT I'LL DO.
HE REMAINS DEFIANT AND INSISTS
HE DID NOTHING WRONG.
>> THE REPORT SAID I SEXUALLY
HARASSED 11 WOMEN, THAT WAS THE
HEADLINE PEOPLE HEARD AND SAW
AND REACTED TO.
THE REACTION WAS OUTRAGE, IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN.
HOWEVER, IT WOULD ALSO FALSE.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT THERE
ARE NOT 11 WOMEN WHO I TRULY
OFFENDED, THERE ARE.
I THOUGHT A HUG AND PUTTING MY
ARM AROUND A STAFF PERSON WHILE
TAKING A PICTURE WAS FRIENDLY,
BUT SHE FOUND IT TO BE TOO
FORWARD.
I KISSED A WOMAN ON THE CHEEK AT
A WEDDING, AND I THOUGHT I WAS
BEING NICE, BUT SHE FELT IT WAS
TOO AGGRESSIVE.
>> HE SAID ALL THAT.
HE COULD ALSO FACE TROUBLE IN
OTHER AREAS FACING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HIS HANDLING
OF THE NURSING HOME SCANDAL AND
HIS PANDEMIC BOOK THAT YOU'LL
REMEMBER PLUS PROSECUTORS ACROSS
NEW YORK ARE PURSUING CRIMINAL
INTO SEXUAL ALLEGATIONS.
THIS IS ONE OF MY MOST
FRUSTRATING PARTS AS WHEN HE
SAID I DIDN'T KNOW THE LINES HAD
BEEN REDRAWN.
HE SIGNED NEW LAWS INTO PLACE
WHICH REQUIRED EVERYBODY IN NEW
YORK STATE EMPLOYEE, YOU HAVE TO
SIT THROUGH THESE
SEXUAL-HARASSMENT VIDEOS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR ON TOP OF THE ONES
FROM THE CITY, HE SIGNED THEM
AND HE DIDN'T EVEN GO TO HIS OWN
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING.
TO GET THAT IS PART OF WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID WHEN SHE
ANNOUNCED A REPORT HE NOT
VIOLATED NOT ONLY LAW, BUT
FEDERAL AND STATE, BUT ALSO HIS
OFFICE OWN POLICIES WHICH
EVERYBODY HAS TO GO THROUGH
THIS, HE CLEARLY THINKS THAT HE
IS ABOVE THE LAW AND ABOVE HIS
OWN RULES.
HE'S NOT SORRY FOR ANY OF IT,
CLEARLY, HIS SICK AND TWISTED
LANGUAGE TODAY WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT WHILE I'M GOING TO HELP
YOU AND THE STATE BY STEPPING
ASIDE, AND I ACTUALLY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING THAT WRONG, AND IT'S
THE WOMEN WHO ARE REALLY
OVERREACTING HERE WITH THEIR
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST ME, AND THEN
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT HOW
GOVERNMENT OPERATING PROPERLY IS
A MATTER OF LIFE AND DEAF, I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A REALLY SICK
TWIST ON THE OTHER ISSUE THAT HE
IS FACING WHICH IS THE NURSING
HOME PROBLEM.
I THINK DEMOCRATS IN THE ARK
ACTUALLY GET OFF THE HOOK HERE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH AN
IMPEACHMENT AND HOLDING A PERSON
IN THEIR PARTY ACCOUNTABLE.
I THINK PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN GETS
A PASS BECAUSE HE CAN SAY WELL,
THEY CALLED ON HIM TO RESIGN, HE
HAS DONE SO, BUT LET'S NOT
FORGET, THE DOJ DROPPED THE
CIVIL RIGHTS INVESTIGATION AND
THEY'RE NOT LAUNCHING CIVIL
RIGHTS INVESTIGATION INTO HIS
OFFICE FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION WHICH THEY
ABSOLUTELY COULD DO IN THIS
CASE.
I THINK DEMOCRATS AT THE TOP ARE
GETTING A PASS AND ANDREW CUOMO
IS CLEARLY NOT RESPONSIBLE.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN, THIS IS A SHORT COMMENT
TODAY ON THE MATTER.
>> I RESPECT THE GOVERNOR'S
DECISION AND I RESPECT THE
DECISION HE MADE.
>> WHICH IS THE SAME THING.
HE DIDN'T SAY HE RESPECTS HIM,
WHICH MIGHT HAVE BEEN AS STEP
TOO FAR.
>> THAT WAS JUST FANTASTIC.
YOU KNOW, THE NARRATIVE TO IS
THIS IS SAID TO THE RISE AND
FALL OF THIS CHARACTER, THIS
LARGER-THAN-LIFE, AND WHAT A
DIFFERENCE A YEAR MAKES WITH ALL
THE SELF-INFLICTED WOUNDS, BUT
NONE OF US HERE PUT HIM ON A
PEDESTAL.
WE ALL KNEW WHAT HE WAS AND WAS
RIGHT THERE WITH ALL THIS STUFF
KICKED OFF.
AND HONESTLY, WE NEVER TALK THAT
MUCH ABOUT HIM AS THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
IT WAS EVERYBODY ELSE, THEY WERE
CREATING THIS MYTH OUT OF THIS
CREEP, AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS
MAYBE HE SAW IT COMING, BUT WHEN
THE PRESS CREATES THIS MONSTER
THE FLAWS BECOME EVEN MORE
VISIBLE.
PEOPLE STARTED LOOKING AT STUFF,
AND AS FOR THE NURSING HOME
STAFF, A LOT OF POLITICAL
LEADERS STAND TO GAIN FROM HIS
DESTRUCTION BECAUSE THEY DID THE
SAME THING, RIGHT?
THERE WERE A LOT OF DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS WHO DID THE SAME THING
WITH NURSING HOMES AND MAY BE
THEY WERE THAT THIS WOULD BE A
WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT WITHOUT
THEM HAVING TO DEAL WITH IT.
IT REMINDS ME OF THOSE CONTEST
WHERE EVERYBODY PUTS HER HAND ON
A CAR AND THE LAST PERSON THAT
SURVIVES, WINS THE CAR.
HE THOUGHT HE COULD OUTLAST
EVERYBODY.
IT'S LIKE THE LAST DANCE FROM
HAPPY DAYS.
REMEMBER THE DANCE CONTEST
FONZIE THOUGHT HE COULD OUTLAST,
BUT NO, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
HE WENT.
>> WHAT'S THE GOING AWAY PARTY
GOING TO BE LIKE?
AND IS CHRIS CUOMO GOING TO DO
THE ONE ON ONE.
>> HE'S ON VACATION THIS WEEK.
HE CONTINUES TO ADVISE HIS
BROTHER.
THE OTHER THING HE SAID AS THAT
THERE ARE GENERATIONAL AND
CULTURAL SHIFTS THAT I DIDN'T
FULLY APPRECIATE.
REALLY?
I REMEMBER HIM GOING AFTER ALL
SORTS OF REPUBLICANS ON THESE
VERY ISSUES.
>> AND HE HAS THREE MILLENNIAL
DOLLARS WHICH WAS A CORNERSTONE
OF KIND OF THE FINAL CORNER OF
THE SPEECH WHICH WAS, TAKING US
BACK TO HOW WELL THE CUOMO'S,
NEW YORK, NEW YORK, AND NO ONE
CAN DENY THAT, THIS IS A FOUR
DECADE DYNASTY WERE LOOKING AT
CRUMBLING HERE AND HE TALKED
ABOUT HOW PAINFUL IT WAS TO
WATCH THE COVERAGE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON SITTING THERE WITH HIS
THREE DAUGHTERS, HIS TWINS ARE
26 AND I THINK THE OTHER ONE AS
24 MAY BE A YEAR OLDER THAN THAT
AND THEY WERE ALSO CENTERPIECES
OF THE EARLY COVID COVERAGE.
MEATBALLS IN DAYS, HE HAD ONE OF
THEIR BOYFRIENDS QUARANTINING
WITH HIM, AND HE DEFINITELY
TRIED TO REGAIN SOME OF THAT
HERO STATUS BUT AS SOMEONE
WATCHING THIS FROM START TO
FINISH, I WAS PARTICULARLY
BOTHERED BY THE LAWYER WHO CAME
OUT FIRST AND WENT AFTER THESE
WOMEN TO SOME DEGREE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE THINGS
YOU NEED TO DO AS YOU PREPARE
FOR A POTENTIAL CRIMINAL LAWSUIT
COMING DOWN THE WAY, BUT THAT'S
NOT GOOD AND THAT'S NOT IN THE
SPIRIT OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
AND UNDERSTANDING THE GRAVITY OF
WHAT YOU'VE DONE.
I WISH THAT SOMEONE WHO GETS
CAUGHT IN ONE OF THESE, AND WE
KNOW THAT PEOPLE OF ALL
POLITICAL PERSUASIONS HAVE BEEN
MASSIVE VIOLATORS, WHY DON'T YOU
SAY THAT THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
FOR GENERATIONS AND THEN BE HELD
TO ACCOUNT.
NOT LIKE TIMES HAVE CHANGED AND
THAT WAS WRONG.
IT WAS WRONG IN THE 50s IT WAS
WRONG IN THE 60s, IT MAY BE MY
DAD IS EVEN WRONG.
>> IS SO THE FIRST WOMAN TO BE
NEW YORK GOVERNOR, WE'LL HAPPEN.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT GOES FOR
HER, SHE'S GOT TO WEEKS TO
PREPARE.
OF COURT APPARENTLY SHE CALLED
HERSELF AN INDEPENDENT DEMOCRAT.
BUT, HUBRIS ALWAYS EXUDES ITSELF
BEFORE THE FALL.
AND THIS GUY, IT WAS BASICALLY
SHAMEFUL IF YOU THINK ABOUT HOW
HE REACTED THAT FIRST DAY.
REMEMBER THAT VIDEO AND TRYING
TO SUGGEST THAT ANYTHING YOU DID
WAS JUST LIKE WHEN BARACK OBAMA
OR GEORGE W. BUSH HUGGED
HURRICANE VICTIMS.
>> I THINK THE HUBRIS LEADS TO
THE FALL.
THEIR WAS A PREVIOUS NEW YORK
GOVERNOR WHO ALSO WENT DOWN
UNDER HIS OWN SEXUAL IN THIS
CASE PROSTITUTION SCANDAL AND I
THINK HE REFERRED TO HIMSELF IS
A CURSE, THAT HE FLEW A LITTLE
TOO CLOSE TO THE SUN.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO PUT
THIS INTO CONTEXT BECAUSE YOU
SAID HE TOOK PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND YOU'RE RIGHT,
IT'S PARTIAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
I NOTICED THE SAME THING THAT
KATIE DID WHICH IS HE YEAH THERE
IS THE STILL THE MATTER OF LIFE
AND DEAF HIM PUTTING THESE
INDIVIDUALS INTO THE NURSING
HOMES AND INSTILL THERE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS ISSUE,
THIS IS A DISTRACTION, IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT DON'T LET IT BE
THE END OF THE STORY.
IT'S NOT THE END OF THE STORY
FOR NEW YORK, YOU BROUGHT UP
OTHER GOVERNORS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND YOU REFERENCED MIGHT
MOVIE REFERENCE WOULD BE CHARLIE
WILSON'S WAR BECAUSE YOU
REMEMBER THE SPEECH THAT WAS
GIVEN ABOUT IS THIS BETTER FOR
AFGHANISTAN AND THE ANSWER IS
ALWAYS WE'LL SEE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT COMES NEXT.
WHEN HE SHOULD JAMES HAD A
POLITICAL INTEREST IN THE
GOVERNOR'S FALL, MANY DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS HAD AN INTEREST IN
HIM GOING DOWN, AND WE WILL SEE
WHAT COMES NEXT AFTER GOVERNOR
CUOMO BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS, HE
IS ONE OF THE LEAST LIBERAL
POLITICIANS IN THE STATE OF NEW
YORK.
>> THAT IS TERRIFYING.